ho ho ho now I have a machine gun we're
back baby it's the across the spoiler
this podcast it's your homeboy heavy
spoilers Kevin spoilers as always joined
by Greg Albert Greg it's going to be
Christmas soon hope you've got the
Christmas spirit how's it going it's
going well man I just realized right now
in this very moment you're wearing an
American shirt and I'm wearing a British
shirt kind of not British is this
British Game of Thrones no I consider a
little bit more British than americ Game
of Thrones is it yeah I can't even read
it I drink eggnog and I know things
little finger you know I mean it was
based on British stuff but it's written
by George RR Martin who's American but
he came to um England and learned all
about the chudah crazy stuff going on in
those days guys Henry VII if he didn't
like you as his wife he changed his mind
one day you were Pro there was a 50-50
chance you were getting beheaded so yeah
good good old times wild people running
the country were crazy back then um and
we will be talking about some crazy
people running companies later on we've
got a lot to talk about this week Greg
how's it been going for you it's been
going so well I know that this man right
here Mr heavy SWS himself at for three
days in a row I've been talking to him
uh because we have such a big time
difference and all the time he's telling
me about how he's working on this edit
for Back to the Future how many edits
did that take you because you did that
yourself I think no I didn't I got the
editors to do it um they did a great job
and then never mind then I was trying to
give you credit no well I pretty much
reedited the the whole thing from the
ground up um eventually because we just
couldn't get it past the copyright and
it did about 45 different versions they
they gave it to me Friday morning it's
now Sunday 8 a uh 8:00 pm I got it done
about 4 pm and what annoyed me Greg was
it was literally seeven sixc Clips at
one point and there was about 30 times
it got flagged on just six second Clips
I got on YouTube the other day they've
got the full version of Spider-Man no
way home in IMAX the full movie just
uploaded to it it was up there for days
and days it got millions of views and
I'm I'm sitting there stressing over
sixc clips and stuff where I'm talking
over the top of it it's a bloody outrage
but that's YouTube for you guys and
that's the kind of things that that
happen um so I've not really had much of
a weekend but going into the weekend in
the movie industry Greg we've got the
the box office numbers for the week um
my Segways are getting much better now
so Wonka is number one it's got a gross
of $39 million in the US um it's coming
off its second week worldwide but first
weekend in America um it was predicted I
think to do between 30 and 40 so it's
pretty much coming at that level I know
a lot of people are saying that it's
bombing um I'm not really sure what what
this was expected to do to be honest
it's not like a a tent pole superhero
movie so I wasn't really expecting it to
do that much anyway and Wonka is kind of
an old franchise as well kind of yeah
well it's a musical it's and musicals
like this tend to they tend to have legs
and they tend to grow over time you guys
remember the greatest showman everyone
said the same say that it was a flop and
then it became a sensation I hate
musicals Greg unless it's Eight Mile
right and we went the wife dragged me
out to the greatest showman about four
weekends it had been out and I just been
like oh every weekend putting it off I'm
not I we'll go see it next weekend went
to it Greg it changed changed my mind on
musicals and I just I think we watch it
we don't watch it now we've got the kids
but every a on U Year's Eve we used to
put it on chill out and just sing along
and put the karaoke version on because I
think the 4K of it got the karaoke
version and it's it's a good old time
that have you seen the clip have you
guys in the comments seen the clip of
Hugh Jackman ah I don't forget the
actress's name when she auditioned and
have you seen this clip and she's doing
it for the first time and he's just like
crying every time I watch it I ball my
eyes out I love a good musical man they
they are so I just watched hairspray for
the first time I love a good musical
what's guys in the comments across the
spoiler verse comments what's your
favorite musical put it in the comments
below and while you're down there hit
the Thumbs Up Button subscribe if you're
not already don't write comments about
how negative we are every week we're
going to try and be positive but it we
don't we don't Cho like deal with the
news guys we choose what stuff like to
report on but it's always bad stuff but
we do we do go in every single week like
we need to have a good positive story
and sometimes it just doesn't happen um
yeah but yeah while you're down there
please hit the Thumbs Up Button um if
you're on the go you can check us out on
Amazon music um on the podcast section
or on Spotify and if you want to support
the channel as a member just click that
join membership button for 99 cents a
month you get early access to these
podcasts and you also get early access
to our classic movie breakdowns as soon
as I finish recording the audio of those
I upload it as its own thing so you can
listen to it on the go and then when we
get the edits done we upload those yeah
and then yeah you guys it really means a
lot to us when you guys do that though
um but yeah second place holding strong
Greg The Hunger Games prequel I'm
telling you it's it's old and strong and
I am gutted because I W I I heard mixed
things about it and I thought I'm not
going to bother doing a video on it and
every couple of days I'll check to see
what the top viewed ending explains are
and like I could do with half a million
views on a video right now because times
is tough but yeah good to see it doing
well I'm guessing it's Rachel zler doing
good you know whenever the people are
quick to report on her boming and
causing trouble but you know in all
fairness this has done uh this has done
well for us so yeah congratulations I
can't wait to watch it here at home
video on demand the way the movie was
meant to be watched just like most of
you guys will do I've got this steel
book uh pre-ordered so looking forward
to that um in third place is the boy in
the Heron with oh sorry I forgot to say
The Hunger Games has made $5.8 million
this weekend the boy and the Heron in
third place has made 5.1 and Godzilla
minus one has made 4.8 which I was going
to go see tonight but Greg you're away
because you're celebrating your
anniversary so we had to move the
podcast date and it's another week where
I haven't keep making excuses for why
you haven't made the time to go watch
Godzilla minus one oh I got to edit this
Back to the Future video like 46 times
oh it's your fault I can't go I got
twins I'm sick whatever meet Santa I
gotta meet meet Santa yeah yeah but yeah
so there's been a big um release the
well not a big release theatrically but
a big talking point this weekend um
which has been Rebel Moon that has come
out some Select theaters the reviews
have not been good mate I tell you that
um when I seen it it was % on Rotten
Tomatoes and then it was 24% and then it
was 9% and it's yeah it's it's getting
kind of lambasted all over social media
but I know I get called a Snider bot
Greg but I always feel with Zack
Snider's movies that there's always this
kind of controversy around them that the
there's a strong the audience score is
about
75% um and the critics score is very low
and it's always kind of that stuff with
um Zack Snider's films but we we know
that there's actually an Extended Cut of
it coming and good friend of mine balam
known him for years and years um he
works for Joe at the moment which if you
guys are in the UK you'll know that he
got to see it early in um interview Zach
as well and he was saying you you can
tell there's a good movie in there but
they've just cut it down so much that
there's not really the chance to stay
with characters and stuff and we know
that there's that Extended Cut coming
and I'm kind of thinking why haven't
Netflix just released the best version
of this film um and it made me start to
do put my old conspiracy hat on Greg and
I started to think what if right they're
just trying to manufacture a sort of SN
cut like movement
because yeah I feel like they they
purpose put it out cut down in the hopes
that it might get bad reviews while also
telling there us there's a much better
cut out there so people will demand that
cut get really excited for it there'll
be a movement on social media and it
feels like they're doing that because
the directors Cuts right the thing is
it's weird when they announce it while
the film's just being released you know
what I mean typically in the past and H
bummer guys's actually done a brilliant
video on director's cut and how they
sort of started as their own thing and
it was very much a case of when a
director got screwed over it would be
years down the line before they got to
do an Extended Cut and for example
aliens with James Cameron so goury
Weaver before she signed on to the film
she gave loads of stipulations about
things she was like look mate I need it
we need to have a thing with my daughter
in it um a backstory she basically
listed off loads of things that they cut
from The Final Cut and she was pissed
about it so when aliens three rolls
around and they start putting that in
place and they're like oh come on do you
want to sign on to aliens 3 like no mate
cuz you [__] up the last one I refus
to do it and they're like don't worry
though an extended Cut's coming we're
going to let James do one and it kind of
feels almost like director's cuts at
this point are sort of a marketing thing
it's like once you've bought the film
it's like oh the director's cut as well
I mean I've the amount of things I've
bought twice because it's a director's
cut and and Ridley so when I was was I
was doing alien the the alien and aliens
for the the classic movie breakdowns
there's even a bit at the start where
you can watch the the forward from the
director and on alien Ridley Scott's
like now the movie I made in that I
released in the cinema was perfect and
that's how I want it but they brought me
in and I've just done a director's cut
just for the sake of it and he basically
says that and it's very much a marketing
piece so what the hell are they doing
with Rebel Moon I was talking I sure I
Echo all the same thoughts that you were
saying right now I was talking with a
producer guy or whatever yesterday I
think and we were having this discussion
because it is odd and a lot of people
share the same sentiment as us of why
not just release it and Zack Snyder in
particular out of anyone when it comes
to a director's cut it's something
that's so associated with him because
it's before Justice League when that
happened I mean I think you Watchmen was
one that people liked but people have
you seen the directors cut Batman v
Superman I think was the real Catalyst
for it when you know I was part of that
camp too I didn't like the theatrical
cut of Batman B Superman I didn't and
and then I saw I I eventually years
later saw um the Extended Cut and
suddenly everything made sense I was
like oh my that it was that uh Danny
DeVito It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
moment I get it now and and then uh of
course we know the Legacy with Snider
cut the difference with this one though
is it is is it just does
feel it feels strangely manufactured in
a way you know because before it was
like oh there's something wrong with
this movie The Studio's wrong Zack
Snyder and that's usually when a
director's cut becomes Monumental uh we
were talking about Ridley Scott you know
I haven't seen it but I constantly hear
about that Kingdom of Heaven movie the
director's cut being exceptionally
better and it actually is a great movie
I hear that all the time from film nuts
and now I'm looking at Rebel Moon and it
it it feels like in a weird way you know
when you know marvel comes out with the
MCU and that every studio is like we
gotta we got to launch a Cinematic
Universe in advance as opposed to how
Kevin feige and company started figuring
out their uh connective storyline as
they went this feels akin to that for me
of you know what why don't we just do it
now in advance except Zack Snyder as
opposed to being ah they they screwed me
over and Netflix is here to save
me it's this announce it's this it's
this um premature announcement of we are
going to release the director's cut
don't you worry and and I'm here just
going do I even want to watch the
theatrical cut then knowing there's the
real authentic version the one that is
undoubtedly going to be better because
here's the funny part is a director's
cut can be semi- manipulative in in the
sense of if there if the theatrical cut
is bad you can watch a director's cut
and by it being better with it being
better by proxy it can trick your brain
into thinking it's a good movie I'm not
saying that every director's Cut Is is
like no it's actually a bad movie you
just think it's good because it's better
but it can have that effect and I like
most of Zack Snyder's films I the only
one I actually haven't seen a sucker
punch so I think I like pretty much
every one of his movies actually I think
I haven't seen the owl
one I haven't se the Guardians of Ghul
is it it's called I haven't seen that
one either yeah I haven't seen those um
but all the other ones I've seen and I
like them I and it does seem I I'm
wondering like maybe did they not have
faith in them my my real conspiracy
theory mind and I would be curious to
know what like the commentators here
have to say my real conspiracy theory
mind is going what if they thought Rebel
Moon actually wasn't good and this would
be the way to make people really believe
it's something Grand and great when that
is a very I don't really believe that
I'm just trying to instigate comments to
increase engagement Paul work with me
buddy work good at that cuz everyone
hates you you
sucker I said this was little finger and
I know people already were going it's
not a little finger but you just you got
to know how to do it man anyway you
manipulate them as well just like how
Netflix manipulate with their director's
cut and that is quite a good point I
think as well with it not it's getting a
theatrical release like in quotation
marks but it's not getting like a
widespread release it's pretty much all
going towards the streaming service
which you know normally when stuff gets
cut down you'll hear like oh well it's
because they want to have so many
showtimes a day and if it's a three-hour
film or whatever they're going to get
less money because they're not going to
be able to showed as much even though
typically longer movies actually do do
quite well in the cinema for example you
know in games three hours um the Lord of
the Rings trilogy and those have got
extended versions as well um but yeah
it's it's weird for a streaming service
to do this because you can pause it and
watch it whenever you want you know what
I mean there's not like you don't need
to fit as many show times in a day and I
think just in general the term
director's cut it often makes people
think well in most examples it is the
the better cut the only one I can think
of off the top of my head that isn't is
probably apocalypse Redux which then had
another cut on top of it which was the
Final Cut which is absolutely brilliant
and I love that film did that for the
channel as well recently um so yeah
there's quite a weird sort of thing and
and way to take things and I I do
personally believe that they've seen
Zack Snider they know his association
with directors CT I mean the amount of
times I bought Watchman I bought the DVD
I then bought the extended version of
the DVD which was called the director's
cut and then bought the Blu-ray and then
they released the director's cut on
Blu-ray and and then they released the
um Ultimate Edition which is 4 hours
long with all the the black braer stuff
in and then I bought that on 4K and then
they did a re-release of it that was
recolored with better HDR and Dolby
vision and stuff and I bought that so
I've spent so much money on this stuff
and like I feel like they're just trying
to bump up the viewing figures and maybe
manufacturer sort of oh wait until the
director's cut comes out because
director's cuts are better and we all
know that deep down in our souls because
Studios metal and ruin things and uh
yeah it's a lot like that and I mean
just the phenomenon of director's Cuts
in general um Citizen Kane was like sort
of where it first started and and auson
Wells kind of got signed off in it and
got complete control of the cut and then
a bit of movie trivia for you but his
Magnificent Ambersons which was a
1942 um period drama that apparently had
like one of the best third acts of all
time but
um Aon Wells didn't actually own the
rights to cut it down or something he
didn't have like he didn't get say on
the Final Cut and the studio met cut it
down it's still seen as one of the best
films ever made but the third Act is
there was loads of film reels of it and
what happened was the studio one day
were just like ah we need to free up the
Vault so just burn all these reals of
this this film so the entire third act
got lost and in the 70s atin WS was even
talking about getting the original cast
back together to refilm the ending um
and yeah stuff stuff like that has
become kind of crazy talking points and
there is almost that myth around when
you hear like this Suicide Squad David
aircut there's kind of a myth about
there sometimes being a better cut out
there and I think it builds hype knowing
that and I think that's what Netflix are
trying to do as well they being like Oh
we might have got bad reviews but
there's a better cut out there and you
guys just need to wait and demand and
tweet about it well Zack Snyder in
particular though be Beyond uh just the
director's cut if you give him one of
his movies really bad
reviews then the quote unquote Snider
cultists they will come out in droves to
support this movie vemi andly you know
like that nothing will stop them they
will be impervious amazing I mean it's
kind of weird how that I think and uh
look I like his movies a lot but when I
read negative reviews of Zack Snider's
films they often go after him and not
necessarily the film itself and it is
kind of weird and there there has been a
bit of backlash um to review reviews and
critics um because some have mentioned
things like the Snider cultists bringing
them up and yeah talking about Bots and
stuff and the the critics themselves
have faced backlash but I don't know if
that EXA yeah it's just a we he is like
a director yeah he's a director that
people focus a lot on and talk about and
yeah I mean it's got people talking
about the movie at least yeah that's
what I mean there's gonna and and when a
movie comes out to this batter reviews
and when there's already people who love
Zack Snyder this much that audience
score is bound to go up like regardless
I think people are going to go on
probably with lower expectations they
going to like it more than what critics
have led them to believe and they're
going to be people who love Zack Snider
so much that they're going to see the
vision for what it really is or perhaps
you know see more into it or give it
more credit whatever it doesn't matter
or they might just think it's a
generally a good movie I don't know my
prediction is this audience score is GNA
climb a lot higher uh than what it is
now or I'll be back here in the new year
with you to tell you oh no it's worse
than before well it's weird for me to
even review it because I want to cover
it on Friday when it releases but I
don't know how I'm going to review it
when I'm like I know there's another cut
of it coming very soon
exactly yeah exactly I'm right there
with you it's strange really strange
this channel even pretty much got
started by reviewing the extended
edition of Batman v Superman because I
didn't like that theatrical cut and what
I was doing at the time on my website
was I've got like pretty much every
single Batman graphic novel over there
right and I was going through all those
graphic novels on my websites and
reviewing them all one by one and then
when the ex Ed version of Batman v
Superman came out I thought I'll do a
YouTube video and that's kind of what
blew the channel up because no one was
talking about the extended version on
YouTube at the time uh yeah and that
kind of is when I got into YouTube so I
mean I kind of got my my channel was
born from reviewing extended editions of
Zach Snider
films yes studio is always kind of
interfering and uh we've heard from Adam
Driver this week in Star Wars news that
JJ br's original plan for kylo Ren was
changed while shooting the character
then this is according to a variety
sorry forgot to credit them and so
variety of said the character was not
going to find Redemption by evolving
into Ben solo and then Adam dri said
JJ's idea was that kylo's Journey was
the opposite journey of Vader where
Vader starts the most confident and most
committed to the dark side and then by
the last movie he's the most vulnerable
and weak he wanted kylo to start with
the opposite his character was the most
confused and vulnerable
and by the end of the three movies he
would be the most committed to the dark
side so what are your thoughts on that
original Arc they had for kylo I think
it would have been much more
interesting I believe this interview was
on the Rich Eisen show and he T his
Cadence to it doesn't sound overly
negative but there is a part in it where
you can read into it
thinking he seems kind of disappointed
by what happened it's one of those
things I I I like what Adam Driver did
really quick quick side note I like what
Adam Driver did with kylo Ren kind of
how Mark Hamill um handled Luke
Skywalker in Last Jedi where they didn't
like the direction of what they were
doing with the characters but man they
still turned in like really great
performances regardless that's a
consumate professional right there as
Adam Driver to me is like best part of
those um well this original Arc though
yeah I mean it I think in terms of
storytelling of a saga especially and to
not just be repetitive and and to really
just do something different that that
you wouldn't expect I think all of us
were the the cliche Arc is where kylo
Ren actually went down and I think a
more badass one just as a fan to watch a
guy
who I remember the reaction for kylo Ren
and the force awakens being like this
guy's kind of a joke whatever and then
you see him in Last Jedi and regardless
what you think about this that movie A
lot of people were really praising Adam
driver's work in that film and I
remember being there going whoa this
would be kind of crazy if they set him
up to be like the ultimate baddy of the
of the Fran of the of the last Trilogy
and it would be such an antithesis to
what Vader went down that I think it
would have complemented the overall
storytelling of of a saga and I do I a
little disappointed by it because it
does just uh shine a light more on the
if you have a plan it should be more
like a guideline it doesn't have to be a
a a a like complete scripture where you
have to stick to it religiously it it
ought to just be treated like a
guideline this seemed like they deviated
so much from it and what is kind of
surprising to me and I'm curious to get
everyone's thoughts too on this as well
what's kind of surprising to me is
that Ryan Johnson regardless of whatever
changes he made it still set up Adam
drivers kylo Ren to go down this same
Arc like when you look at what happens
in that movie it's it's still
essentially you can still do that Arc
that was originally pitched him the one
that JJ Abrams originally had in mind
that when he came back to do rise of
Skywalker they still could have done it
so I I don't really know what it was all
I can do is theorize of I don't know
Disney saw memes of kylo Ren and Ray
and yeah rlo let's do it
I don't know what it was well that was
another thing that driver said in the
interview he was saying that he aimed
his performance in those films with that
in mind as being the end goal um yeah
and yeah for for JJ Abrams though to be
the person who's like we're doing things
differently that kind of strikes me a
bit as odd because from what I've seen
of his Star Wars films he's trying to
make things everything exactly the same
as how it was originally like the rise
of Skywalker yeah I just feel like it's
non-stop pandering um and trying to swap
things back to how it was and just
Pander to the fans as much as possible
like they bring Palpatine back out of
thin air even though he hasn't been set
up at all in that those other two films
you know and then they're like he's
raised Grandad kylo was lying about it
and Star Destroyers can destroy full
planets now so yeah it's just like the
Death Star and there's thousands of them
as well and that whole movie uh I know
the Last Jedi has s but I feel like Ryan
Johnson actually made you know he might
not agree with the direction but you can
see that he was telling a sort of full
story in that movie where it was things
made sense sort of and you might
disagree with the choices but things at
least continued in a certain way whereas
rise is just all over the place and it's
McGuffin Central and it's crazy how how
I I think it's by far the worst Star
Wars film sorry guys I know you want
admet to be positive but I think it's
it's h very bad and yeah just even just
the kiss with kylo and Ray at the end
it's just out of nowhere it's clearly
just pandering to fans who wanted Rao
and yeah just kind of all over the place
so what was the reaction in the theater
for you when that Happ did you watch it
with a packed audience when that
happened I remember exactly I've only
seen it the one time and I remember
exactly what that reaction was like we
live in England so we don't really react
in theaters you know what I mean you
never get you never get applauses at the
end of the film I think if you came here
and watched a film out in England you at
the end you'd be like surprised at how
little reaction there is there the odd
kind have you never had that experience
of just a stuff but you but you never
had like that endgame experience of
people like I remember the first time I
had that was Return of the King I saw it
on Christmas day that it came out one
with my mom and I had never been a part
of that where everyone just would not
stop cheering have you never actually
had that experience before different
cultures Mate different cultures just
reserved and yeah I never visiting that
is awful don't you're not welcome here
you cannot have a reaction Channel it
would ruin it for me Greg if people were
standing I'm trying to listen to the
movie I have to do a
breakdown yeah there's been a number of
times where I know there's been like a
post credit scene in a film and I've
wanted to double check with you like
what's said in it to make sure that I've
got things right and you're like I
honestly couldn't hear cuz people were
just screaming over the top of it and
I'm sitting there like oh crap what I
going write where yeah in England you
could hear a pin drop I do remember when
Andrew Garfield popped out of the portal
in no way home we had like wo and that
was it people I mean you'll get the
you'll get laughs in in comedy movies
people aren just sitting there like
Stone faac in the comedy you get people
laughing but no one's clapping in a in a
movie theer I'm guessing maybe at the
London premieres they do if the director
there or something but
yeah people in the comments if you know
if you've had a different experience in
England then let me know but yeah dead
it's like a funeral in there that's so
sad it's just a bunch of Royal Guards
watching I feel so sad hearing this man
guns on the crowd yeah so stoic it's the
worst place to do test audiences in
England we have no idea how anyone feels
um
wild oh oh well I mean when okay well I
saw the right back to the original
that's I'm so mind blown by this uh I
had no idea the with the railo kiss that
I saw it at the uh at not the premiere
but like one of the advanced screenings
and half the audience cheered and the
other half was laughing
maniacally at what happened and that to
me is the ultimate Testament of we don't
know what to do how do we Pander to
everyone and uh yeah R like Last Jedi is
the forever debate all you got I just
put out one tweet and you could see that
it's oh wow that that rage carries on uh
but at least it had a voice you know
that's the one thing is that at least
there was a voice and even with the
prequels you can say that if you don't
like them or you think they're bad films
whatever at least there's a voice to it
and Rise of Skywalker is the only one
that genuinely does not feel like it has
a voice I would say solo to a certain
degree actually actually solo I is
better but well my be director cut out
there the whole movie and then reshot it
I would love to see that version though
who would not want to see the Phil Lord
and Chris Miller version of that I would
love to see yeah I mean what's crazy as
well is like Star Wars has kind of had
its own director cut all the time with
special editions and stuff but um Disney
in general just don't tend to release
alternate versions of their films for
example like there's lots of MC when
when DC started doing things like the
extended version of Batman v Superman
and Suicide Squad and stuff I thought oh
we're g to get extended versions of the
MCU as well because they realized like
they can sell the movie twice but
they've never done an extended version
even the ones that got badly reviewed um
and Star Wars as well solo I think
people do want to see that Lorden Miller
version because it's pretty much out
there I mean they they apparently shot
the majority of the movie and then
reshot it and reworked it yeah and I
think that would actually do well and
you know Star Wars has had its special
editions and yeah there's lots of
different cuts of Star Wars out there as
well with depending on how much you like
CGI or not you can enjoy lots of
different robots floating around in the
background so it's been a big week for
for space movies anyway Greg I'm
segueing into Jun so they did a new
trailer for June part two the third
trailer I decided not to cover it um
yeah it's kind of trailer threes in
general guys in case you you you don't
know how YouTube Works your views are
always strongest with the first trailer
bit lower on the second trailer third
trailer you viewed are pretty much dead
um and yeah I love the trailer to be
honest but there was so much going on in
it I thought this is going to take me
forever to break down and I'm never
going to get back to the future finished
so unfortunately I didn't do
um but they they had already sold the
movie to me they' already sold it I was
already very hyy to see it but seeing
this I thought this is great I haven't
seen the trailer I used to be the guy
who would cover every trailer and any TV
spot and all that and now I'm at this
point in my life
where I mean yeah like views sure do
matter but even on my own time I I was I
have I still haven't seen it because I'm
like I feel like I've seen enough but we
have different approaches for what we do
on our our own separate content and you
know like you need to get all the
details and the breakdown you need to
read the book and I could go in like I
don't know anything I'm going to
experience this for the first time and
give you guys my opinion so we have very
different uh experiences we have to
convey uh but looking at the view count
for what it getting here all right dude
in part two the official trailer got 25
million views part two uh the second
trailer got 22 million views and the
third trailer it's only been five days
it's only at 9.1 million views I don't
know if that's something to cause
concern is there anything in the trailer
that feels truly different I don't mind
hearing stuff about it uh is there
anything though that feels truly or is
it just a reminder that don't worry it's
still coming it's still coming out yeah
it's your usual trailer 3 thing where
it's kind of like ex some landscape
shots we haven't seen before big
explosions um bigger character shots
Crazy Character moments but it's the
characters that you you already know
there's not I wouldn't say that there's
not well it's it's a great trailer but
um I wouldn't say it really does
anything that it's like if you if you go
into the move I don't know I I don't
tend to watch that many trailers unless
I'm like doing it for the job but yeah I
think it's a great trailer you should
probably watch it but it's not there's
nothing that I saw in it where I was
like oh man I can't believe they
revealed this or something it's just
kind of more expanding on what we've
seen before and yeah it looks great but
Louis uh Lu Fernando who we often use
his takes for the box office he's put
out a tweet talking about how basically
he thinks that June part two should have
been released in December with Aquaman 2
taking up its space in March um and he's
basically said
that you know these are Christmas it
feels like a big Christmas movie a big
Christmas event and Aquaman doesn't
really necessarily feel like that and
that takes us into our next story which
is about Aquaman to and yeah the the Box
Office tracking for it is quite low it's
um between 32 million to 42 million it's
you know the first the first film did I
think it was 65 million first weekend
and but it had legs and as we know it
got a billion dollars but yeah it's just
something about this coming out people
don't seem as hyped I wonder if I'm
going to do a quick search if we can see
what it CU most of the box office for
Aquaman came in from internet naal so I
wonder if we can see what the well while
you're looking up that I'll say what
Jason Mamoa has said about returning as
Aquaman or Aquaman he said if the
audience love it then there's a
possibility but right now I'm like it's
not looking too good so not really a
good thing to say in the buildup to
promote any movie Greg I I think he
wanted to die it's going to float to the
bottom of the ocean This aquam Man movie
this when we Zoom when we Zoom together
we
interrupt shut the [__] up so um yeah
this is coming in Wake of the news that
Warner Brothers Discovery currently has
an 60% probability of bankruptcy and I
feel like they're in the boardroom going
we've had lots of bombs this year DC
especially is done terrible Jason Mamoa
we need you to go out and sell this
movie and he's come out and being like
it's not looking good like didn't you
just say that yeah Warner Brothers I
mean we we also had a report talking
about how all of the DC movies are
getting licensed to tuby now a
Tubi yeah which is crazy and it just
feels like and you know this seems to be
what's happening over at the company
that David zaslav is just gutting it for
pot and selling it off to whoever he can
to kind of make as much money as
possible before they then sell the
company again and there have been rumors
that you know Universal are interested
in buying them which I hope isn't the
case because of their copyright system
on YouTube which would completely kill
me but yeah it's very strange it's all
sad DC is getting ruined because of the
company that owns them man this is
gnarly who would have thought we'd be in
such a predicament with DC down the road
what's going on with this Warner
Brothers thing do you know what's
happening with the have we Segway there
yet Paul do we know what's happening
with the zoff situation and Warner
Brothers going bankrupt because I don't
know much about that whole thing I mean
they've just made so many bad financial
decisions really I mean even the strikes
that's clearly I suppose they would have
spent money if the actors were still
working but just the fact that it's
caused so many delays um June had to get
pushed back for
example um so many films sier of bomb
they've had a number of different
layoffs um Executives coming and going
and yeah it's just kind of all up in the
end they've made so many bad decisions
as far as financials go Bobby's done
really well the the CNN streaming
service or some [__] like that I forgot
they so they spent half a billion on the
CNN streaming service as well and then
just mothballed it and it's just like
throwing away money like that and it's
insane and there's been so many bad
decisions with them I swear to God Greg
if we don't get June Messiah and house
the Dragon season 3 I'm going to go
bloody mental CU HBO all by Warner
Brothers and stuff and I'm going to go
[__] mental um and it just kind of
feels like James guns DCU might not even
get made and from what I've been seeing
right and this is just a theory time
guys but it seems like Superman Legacy
they're going full into production with
that everything's going ahead on that
but they're kind of holding back on the
other projects that are going to follow
it and you haven't really heard much
about them you just heard about that and
what Matt reevs is doing with the DCU
and it does kind of feel like they're
almost holding back to see if that's
going to be a success first before then
launching into all this other stuff and
that that's kind of the moves that they
have to make unfortunately because
flopped so many times back to back
consecutively bobbie's done brilliant um
that was a crazy Smash Hit brilliant but
other than that I mean they wasted so
much money like the flash as well and
yeah it's just been Mis fire after
misfire with the company so 60% you know
it's not it's not all doom and gloom but
if someone's like there's a 40% your
company isn't going to go bankrupt if
you flip it around there it's it sounds
really bad yeah if there's even a 1%
chance it'll go it's weird take
it when when you're saying about James
gun though that the pun one of the
positive signs to to me about that
is when you have James gun it's it's a
very unique position This Guy's in
because he's not only the CEO of DC
Studios he's also a filmmaker who's G to
be making films while overseeing he has
to be Kevin feige and James gun all in
one you know that it's a very odd
position to be in like what that's one
part of it that makes it exciting
because it doesn't have to be CFO um
which is why I forget what's the other
guy's name Peter is it Peter saffron is
is that the other guy I forget his name
yeah um and that's why you have Peter
saffron there to help balance that out
right but still he still has to be the
guy is overseen the larger pitcher and
to get it done
correctly then being him being forced
into a position where yeah we're not
hearing about all a lot of these other
movies down the road but that's kind of
a good thing because he h it's it's
going to make that debut film that much
better because all the pressure is on it
to make that won a great film if
anything it's weirdly made me more
confident in what he'll pull off with
Superman Legacy because so much
pressure's writing on it and he can't
really focus on all the other things if
he was having to like announce this and
announce that and you know spread
himself really thin while having to helm
this film that he wrote and directed I I
think that would be way too much for one
individual to tackle and I I I have more
faith in this because pressure's on man
and pressure can create diamonds so I'm
holding out holding out hope that's all
Marvel's the perfect example of a
company that were completely and I don't
know how many times I've heard this
quote about them being so like low money
that they had to sell filing cabinets
and stuff but I mean look at how much
they bounce back and if you get the
right person in the role who's
creatively focused and they do something
amazing they can come back so positive
news guys there 60% that it could go
bankrupt but I'm hoping and praying
because I do as much as a rag on Warner
Brothers I I love the studio that well
what they've made anyway they've made
some absolute Classics I think HBO is an
incredible they're just head and
shoulders above so many other television
networks in terms of what they put out
um Harry Potter films love that like new
they've just had so many big films and I
I do hope that
they they pull things together they
realize this report and just kind of do
things right but and I hope that David
zlab isn't just gotting the company to
to sell it and and move it on I hope
that James gun gets to see his his full
plan through and yeah he's actually been
out this week talking about porn cameos
so uh Cameo porn sorry not porn cameos
probably get demonetized for saying that
but James G has said that Cameo porn is
one of the worst things about recent
superhero films he said if a character
is in a film they have to have a reason
to be there story-wise I don't mind
actual cameos if it's a glimpse or a
moment an Easter egg what bothers me is
when they mangle An Elegant Story by
shoehorning characters in they aren't
there because the story calls for it but
some other
reason so what are your thoughts on that
Greg I remember a scene in The Flash
which he called one of the greatest
superhero movies of all time where they
just had CGI cameos of dead actors shoe
into that for some reason but I thought
that was the greatest movie ever made or
whatever he said about that uh yeah I I
mean it's it is one of those things
where I
agree with the sentiment I I
wholeheartedly agree with the statement
and then you
question the person who's making it
because you go but wait a minute you
were the guy who just promoted the hell
out of this one movie said it was one of
the greatest movies ever made and it's
kind of kind of like uh you know a lot
of times we look at the leader on things
and what we were talking about Warner
Brothers and and and David zoff and I
think part of the detriment that's
happening is Who David zoff is and the
reputation he's developed how PE if
people want to work with him and what
not I think he's he himself just the
image he's garnered for himself has
affected the company and I think stuff
like this with James gun as well it's
the second he said it and I went on
Twitter like other people have got to be
thinking the exact same thing and yeah
is the first thing that comes to mind is
wait a minute dude I know in your actual
what's good about this is he's probably
he's not as much as we've heard the
amount of rumors of characters who could
appear in Superman Legacy and it seems
like that will be the film set up to
Branch out a lot of these uh movies
going forward I I think he will handle
whatever appearances or cameos um with
delicacy with care um and I I agree with
the statement but at the same time yeah
I'm I'm right there with you on the
people ding on
him even saying they hate him they even
saying what about Justice League in
Peacemaker did that serve a purpose so
people are on Twitter are dunking on
them it was the finale Greg they showed
up at the end of Peacemaker and they did
the dick the fish joke with Aquaman oh
yeah yeah it kind of served a purpose
yeah I mean I I think cameos get a bad
rep in all honesty I think cameos when
people say it now as an insult they kind
of mean like oh they just thrown any
characters in but and they'll talk about
no way home and Multiverse of Madness
but even in that I feel like no way home
the the characters that they brought in
they served the plot and they made a lot
of sense Multiverse of Madness with the
Illuminati made a lot of sense and yeah
I don't know why I think when people
people say Cameo por and they kind of
mean just they they say is an an insult
towards a film and like oh there just
hundreds of cameos but I can't off the
top of my head think of something that a
cameo massively where like massively
ruined the film I mean the Christopher
ree thing in the flash show was kind of
like they do but I don't know Greg
people seem to like them so they just
dumped them in but I would say yeah
you're in a glass house James and hold
in a stone so yeah especially in I'd say
comic book movies are like the number
one offender for cameos and probably one
Brothers has got so many I mean how many
times how many times have we hear that
Wonder Woman theme in the DC EU where
Wonder Woman just showed up about like
Shazam 2o and it's just like and she
just walks along slowly say you all
right you're all right and I get that's
building off a joke from earlier in the
movie but yeah Warner Brothers is the
studio that tend to do it came are are
negative um when they seem like they're
the reason the movie exists is when a
cameo is negative you know but if you
put a cameo in any good film it's
awesome it's exciting I love C who come
anyone who wants to act like cameos are
always bad like that's just not true
like cameos are freaking sweet they're
really cool it's just when you know they
it's like certain movies that have come
out Rec not long ago where they'll
advertise or tease a cameo as a way to
sell a movie and not rely enough on the
actual film itself you know that's when
it feels exploitive Cameo versus uh a
fun Cameo you know yeah I think you've
you've nailed it there I think it is
down to kind of how these movies are
marketed where it's like like in post
credit scenes are another thing where
it's kind of like don't care about the
movie but there's a big post credit
scene at the end it's kind of like well
can you just give us a good movie that
doesn't rely on cameos and having a big
post credit scene yeah yeah exactly
exactly so maybe James was right what
did you think of the Cameo while we're
on the subject the only thing I could
really think of was and it's only
because I saw it was listed in the
little document you made here in the
Batman when Joker appeared that I like
the deleted scene a lot the one that
felt like yeah I
love but in the theatrical version when
we watched the movie in the theaters I I
was part of the audience that was going
I really don't think we needed this
scene I re it was like the only part of
the movie that I would have been totally
fine with removing uh what completely
agree okay completely agree and it from
what I've heard on the Batman 2 it
doesn't necessarily sound like that's
even playing a major part in it so right
yeah I don't know if they even needed it
in there to set set up what's to come
and but that kind of takes us into the
next section which is the Batman 2 and
Matt Reeves in the
DCU so it's actually been said by James
G on threads I believe that right now
Matt is producing Arkham as a DCU Series
so his DCU series uh is going to be set
in the DCU his Arkham series is going to
be set in the DCU um and guns basically
clarified that the the Batman Universe
will have stuff that he's producing
specifically for that but he'll also be
producing stuff specifically for the DCU
as well so he's working in two universes
which yeah I feel like you might have
been red into that you know
Greg yeah I mean wait so the
Arkham am I'm if I'm understanding what
you're telling me the Arkham show or
whatever is that's in the DCU the Batman
movie is in its elor is that what I'm
being told right now the
penguin yeah the penguin B the Batman is
often its own thing but the do you
remember it was a gcpd show originally
and then it got changed to an Arkham
series well it's went from being in Matt
Reeves's Universe to now being in the
DCU and connected to that I don't know
if he's been strong armed in I kind of
feel like it won't get made in all
honesty I feel like Matt Reeves might
have a bit too much on his plate because
we've also had Daniel rpk who's just
dropped a report saying that he's
working on a professor Pig um series as
well so yeah it's kind of weird I I I do
really hope that Matt Reeves just gets
to play in his own Universe just that's
his thing um but I mean he's a great
Creator so I can see why they would want
him as part of the DCU but it kind of
feels like this you know it's went from
a gcpd project to an Arkham project and
now being in the DCU it kind of feels
like this Arkham thing is maybe a bit
all over the place
creatively uh 1 million per. especially
when you have a creative producer like
like Matt Reeves involved it has to
distinguish itself like so much so to
the point where when you like when I see
the penguin other than the fact that
Colin Ferell is there it feels the
little bits we saw it feels like it's
part of the Batman world as it's
supposed to and if you're going to do an
Arkham show I my immediate Association
would be that it's part of the Batman uh
Universe this El world's universe that
is the subsidiary is the Batman world
and uh that's the part of it that can be
really strange to me about this whole
thing did you also hear about um that
thing where I saw something going around
about James gun and talking with Todd
Phillips about Joker 2 and him giving
yeah did said he gave it
notes I did not think James gun he said
put my wife and brother is was first
first notes [__] hell we're
definitely getting the comments Now Greg
Jesus he said he's also heard the pitch
for the Batman 2o but there's no script
yet no script and he talked to yeah and
he also that's when he also talked about
um jok and how he gave notes to it and
it was like again like no matter what he
says people kick off about it because I
remember seeing the comments on that
saying but Todd Phillips made a billion
dooll movie with the joker why does he
need to take notes from James gun it's
like well he's the head of DC Studios
mate proba trying to offer his
advice he's he's going again regardless
ah man I'm really hoping Superman Legacy
kills it I really am because this
James gun I I the pendulum swing on
reputation for this guy is phenomenal
you know to to go from what happened
with guardians and people loving him and
then you start seeing some people like
clowning on him for what how Guardians
kind of change some of the voice of the
MCU then he gets fired and everyone's
like you're wrong James G we love you
James G then he gets rehired he does
Suicide Squad a James gun's great and
then he gets hired for DC Su like what
are you doing you're ruining DC James it
this the the amount of back and forth
with this one guy it's insane to me when
most of the time like when he does
something people tend to like what he
does so why don't we focus on that
because he tends to make good [__] at
the end of the day when when he makes
something it tends to even the stuff
that were like I don't know I had no
interest in a peacemaker show and I
thought it was great so I think this guy
knows how to do phenomenal things and
for him to take on even things like
breitburn that he's involved in you know
what I mean I I enjoy it and but even
that people are like worried that
because he made breitburn that he
doesn't know how to do Superman it's
like well no if you understand breitburn
then you can understand Superman because
you're taking the same elements and just
twisting them off to the dark so if you
can twist them to the light it's kind of
this but look fans are going to be fans
and the amount of times with comic book
castings and directors and stuff that
people
get angry about it and the Matt Reeves
thing as well like yeah I think
everyone's going to have their opinion
on it and the the fans are impassionate
about it but normally normally if
something's really good people tend to
support it when it releases which I'm
hoping happens I hope it's good and I
hope people support it and we're back on
track because that Batman Universe that
Matt Reeves has created absolutely love
it the Joker one that Todd Phillips has
created think it's fantastic and James
gun if he can bring us this in the DCU
as well and we have three strong
continuities involving DC I think I'd be
glad I'd be very very happy be very
happy me too me too what I'm not happy
about Greg is what if so unfortunately
guys I've made the decision that yeah I
don't think we're going to be covering
the full season for the channel and it's
not it's just because of when it
releases it's not because I'm not
excited to do it it's just unfor
fortunately they've we we got the news
the other day that the screeners weren't
coming out until the Thursday and it
releases the Thursday night and we've
got Rebel Moon and Aquaman as well and
yeah I just thought instead of theory
time it was time to do some family time
so unfortunately guys I'm really sorry
I'm going to try and cover as much as I
can I'm going to be working through the
week but yeah I I feel just with it
releasing day after day after day it's
going to be so hard to keep up on
especially during Christmas and I know
other people are having the the same
difficulty um Ryan at screen crush is
like he's locked sponsors in for it as
well and he's really like stressing
about how he's going to get it done and
just it was it's kind of a weird
marketing pitch Greg like I don't get
why they're they're doing this um and
yeah we were talking about the other day
and it was kind of like how can we make
this as awkward as possible for people
covering the show well like we'll
release nine in a row day the day okay
but yeah but how do we make it more
Awkward we released out of a Christmas a
new year okay but how do we make it even
more Awkward we give them the screeners
on the day of so there's not even any
point in watching them to cover the show
so yeah it's just kind of weird and it's
made me think like Disney are are doing
so much weird marketing at the moment um
and I don't think they realize that how
much we do them like not us specifically
but how much the Press do marketing for
free for for them so if they send out a
show and it gets buzzed the Press will
do most of the marketing for them for
absolutely nothing because they'll be
writing their articles on it
interviewing the cast and getting sound
bites and and Inter and even the memes
and stuff and there's so much free
marketing out there on social media that
it's kind of weird for them to take the
strategy especially because we've got
Echo so early Greg and I don't know if
we're allowed to talk about that yeah
Echo came out so early and yet that is
the most bizarre part of it all to me we
got echko remarkably early and I haven't
seen it yet but we got it like so early
just like thanks where's what if where's
what Happ a what if because that's
coming out during Christmas and it takes
many hours to put one of these videos to
you know what I mean like it's I
understand we don't have like the
hardest job in the world I I completely
get it guys we don't um at the same time
like many of you we would just like want
to be able to everything we do is so
time sensitive though and and like we're
obedient to like algorithms and adherent
to these things so we and we want to
spend time with our families and stuff
the amount of flak I get from my family
for like I'm like I I can't go out or I
can't do this just yesterday I went out
for a little bit uh to this like holiday
event and the people who know me they
were like oh my God you're out of the
house I'm like yeah I managed to make it
work but I got to get up early the next
day guys so I can't stay long you know
and and because I'm just trying like
like you you know and you got you got
like a whole freaking you got kids and
stuff like I'm I'm trying to just get
ahead where I can have Christmas day off
you know and uh just taking two days off
this month is is a little rough and so
yeah what they're doing what if is is a
really strange thing when they know that
most of the people uh Mo most of their
journalists and stuff like yeah they all
have to work on it and it is a strange
thing for to put the people they rely on
but I don't know maybe maybe we haven't
been kissing Disney's ass enough or
something I don't know let's PL it yeah
well another thing was my editors asked
for it off as well and I was like well I
I gave them it off I was like of course
he's can have it it's Christmas um and
then I was like mt Mt mate the editors
are all off so there's not really much
point in you working it do you want it
off as well and he was like yeah thanks
man I'll have it off as well so they're
all getting it off and and I think I I
probably will work some days but it's
not going to be that's why I don't want
to commit to what if because I know that
I'm not working every single day and
with it releasing every single day it'll
be like yeah why have you done episode
four today but you're not done one to
three so I was thinking of actually
doing what I did with love death and
robots which was after the series
wrapped up I just picked my favorite
episodes from That season and talked
about them and I'm sure I'm sure some
will be better than others um and yeah
I'm just going to watch it through and
then decide that but Ekko is going to be
an I don't think we're actually allowed
to talk about it Greg I don't think the
reaction embargo lifted yet I'm sure the
review embargo day
and uh yeah we'll talk about that you
can say what you because we are
technically a social media platform so
you can say what you would say on
Twitter is is my understanding like that
kind of I don't even know if that's
lifted because I know people went to the
event and saw the first two and they
reacted to it but I don't know if people
with screeners were allowed to react to
it oh oh yeah yeah that's right they get
there's strange rules to this and yeah
you were telling about what if with the
videos and and that's true because I was
thinking well sometimes you if a like
when a when a Netflix season comes out
you usually will just do uh an ending
explain of the Season like you don't do
every episode so I was like yeah you can
just do it for what if but it's
different for what if because it's an
anthology show and it's not the same as
telling an overall one serial life story
so you would essentially be having to do
nine videos in one giant video If you
were to do that so it's not the same
thing as do entire season Marvel
released the episode names this week and
the finale is called what if Doctor
Strange Supreme intervened so I'm guess
well we've seen the trailer as well we
know strange Supreme is in it so it will
link in with the first season in some
way and it will um I'm guessing that
that from the that episode title again
haven't seen the episodes but I'm
guessing that means they're all going to
kind of coales together in the same way
that the first season did as well you
know that had that kind of introduced
you to all the characters and then at
the end it was like the Guardians of the
Multiverse or whatever they were called
they they all got brought together by
The Watcher to defeat infinite Ultron um
so I'm guessing something like that will
happen I know it's Peggy Carter versus
the Hydra stomper as well um so that's
going to be in it the Gamora from season
one her episode's finally getting
released that was a deleted episode they
they basically made that for season one
but I don't think they got it finished
on time um so they ended up deleting it
well not deleting it but saving it for
this one so yeah might cover those ones
but we'll see um and I've been just
checking out some of the movies that
I've missed this year Greg and I watched
killers of the flower moon really
enjoyed it Greg enjoyed it too bloody
much because uh that Martin scorey he is
a phenomenal director I don't know why I
said enjoyed it too bloody much I sound
like I wasn't celebrating people getting
killed and stuff I enjoy it for all the
wrong reason as a piece of film I
thought it was brilliant I think there's
a really tense atmosphere to it and just
the score throughout it's kind of like
a it's just a very simple score and it
kind of reminds me of like the thing um
score where it's just very isolated just
one single note but it's very tense and
that there's a feeling of dread
throughout the entire film oh yeah and
to know it's based on a true story it's
it's crazy it's just it it basically is
the story of how money is the root of
all evil and how greed just turns people
completely evil and callous and like oh
such an incredible film um the way it
shot I think the way it's edited as well
it does kind of have that good Fellas
flare to it almost where it's the some
of the ways that it's cut up and yeah I
thought it was brilliant so uh not a
massive part of the video but I just s
I'd talk about that also that last of us
actors in it the guy who played
um oh is it David I think it's David in
The Last of Us oh that's where he's from
the second I had no idea until you said
it I was like yeah I saw David from last
of us and then I remember watching the
movie going who is this guy yes yes yes
oh my God genius Paul always plays a
creep always he's a good creep man he's
a good creep dude how great is ly
Gladstone in that movie brilliant yeah
the full cast as well fantastic um yeah
Leonardo DiCaprio playing an idiot with
fake teeth in fake nose I think he's
great at playing Southern idiots I'll
tell you man besto as well Deniro's
range of being like a a really likable
fun Grandpa figure that you kind of
gravitate towards and see is like a warm
figure who's like looking after his
nephew who's just came to town but he's
pushing him towards murdering his family
and killing people and the Dynamics of
it are are insane and it's yeah it's
such a well-made film definitely check
it out if you guys haven't they got a
lot of like uh the actual a lot of like
oage people involved to really make sure
that it was a lot of I know one of the
criticisms is that they wished the film
was and I and I did walk away actually
feeling this way too was that I wish a
more of the film was sort of from Lily
Gladstone's perspective I understand
from a narrative start like I I'm two
minds about it and I do kind of wish
that we did have more from LLY
Gladstone's perspective uh however they
did get a lot of the O people uh
involved and to make sure they it was
handled with a certain level of
authenticity and delicacy as well and uh
yeah we just had Thanksgiving and and
and and I spent my whole Thanksgiving
watching videos about what really
happened on this wonderful holiday so
yeah [__] interesting time we live in
man do we have any stories kind of that
controversy isn't there well there is a
controversial one so Melissa Barrera
apparently and I've saved this until
last in case because there are people
going back and forth over whether it's
true so apparently spy glass asked
Melissa Barrera to have a meeting with
them um she walked into it and they
asked her to return and she said no and
then basically yeah turned down what
they had to offer now I don't know if
that's true it's not been relased
sufficient but that that those were the
rumors this week Greg I could believe
that
story it's one of those things where I
wouldn't know how to feel if she did
agree unless her social media if her
social media changed suddenly she's not
talking about all the things she really
wants to talk about after getting hired
then I'd be like oh meliss Barrera you
done sold your soul girl you know then I
would be in that camp and and and and
this is uh uh is a really sensitive
subject still I understand um but if she
was asked back in the room I don't know
if they would do you think they would I
they probably they I could see I could
totally believe spy glass was like [__]
we've been getting clown on people
really mad at us for what we did we got
to talk to this woman I could totally
believe it do you believe it yeah I mean
they've got so much backlash over it I I
can see them wanting to try and work
something out but yeah the that's the
thing with these corporations man they
just feel like they can pick you up and
drop you and if you say something that
they think's going to cost their money
and they think if they wave money in
your face that you'll come crawling back
to them and do what they want and yeah
good for her if this is true
Sodom yeah yeah hell yeah I just went to
the post from find you're the top
comment you're cool I'm happy really oh
man yeah man and all you said was
good yeah that was it good top comment
that's what I like to see that day still
killing it still killing it my friend so
yeah thanks again for joining us on it's
a shorter one this week Greg but I feel
like we we're we're back we're got the
pacing down Greg I feel like all those
stories flowed really well and I didn't
really have much pre on for this but uh
yeah thanks a lot guys for for sticking
with us I don't know what we're going to
do for Christmas yet we haven't worked
it out but I do I read a comment last
week I read yeah I read a comment last
week Greg I feel like we should do
another episode because I read a comment
from someone saying you know you guys
obviously have your own plans and stuff
but this this podcast really means a lot
to us that I think it was when we missed
the week and and they were saying that
you
know I'm spending Christmas alone and
it's just it's just nice to have
something to listen to and enjoy and I
thought you know what we should do it
for that guy and we'll try work
something out and just be spending
Christmas alone next week or something
we'll we'll try and get an episode out
for you guys to just kind of just have
something to listen to and hopefully
kill an hour's time and enjoy yourself
have a laugh have a think have a bit of
negativity sent you away from the two
guys who are constantly negative about
everything I would say we were pretty F
like without even trying I think we were
pretty because sometimes we have to make
like a conscientious effort to balance
it out and I think we didn't have any of
that going in today I'm pretty we were
pretty balanced today without uh it's
just the stories that come out yeah
control the stories I think in general
right and this this is something I've
I've noticed from doing this podcast is
that negative press gets more engagement
than positive does and it's not
necessarily something we've done
conscientiously but I think just the way
the way I I run the podcast is
throughout the week if I see a story
I'll just note it down and get a tweet
where it's got the quote in it and then
we can talk about that that but I think
the the people I follow they're doing
the negativity Greg they they like
variety and stuff they know they know
negativity cells headlines so that's all
that they write about so it ends up I
end up taking that to including the
podcast and it's like maybe it's just
the media spin in general it's just all
negativity I mean it's rare just the
news cycle in general I mean if youve
ever seen bowling for Coline they have a
big section on that about how the news
works and how it's constantly pushing
fear on you to get you to consume stuff
and maybe we're just a reflection or a
mirror of the way that the new cycle
runs so if we're negative it's because
that's the stories we being fed Greg but
we're trying keep an up beating Jolly
happy chappy smile about it and talk
about it I mean it's just movies at the
end of the day a lot of the time
obviously sometimes it drifts into more
sad stories but um yeah thanks for
joining us and we hope you've enjoyed it
thank you guys yeah I love shooting the
the [__] here this is this is always uh
relaxing and Paul has to be the expert
not me so you know I'm I'm well I don't
have a social life Greg so this is like
my one hour of a week where I get to
just have a social life apparently you
British people don't talk
so even when you go to the cinema it's
not that social it's kind of sh sh don't
Che don't Che I don't care if Matt Murdo
back is Daredevil in a lawar sh you smir
what he's saying I'm trying to make the
bre
you do the Mr Burns one he shows up you
don't you don't do you don't plot
yeah you you do a little you with your
tea and your spoon is the what you guys
are do I don't know what the hell you
guys do yeah bunch of freaks out
there there goes Mr
Murdock I don't know what you guys say
sound like Al righty I think we we drag
this out we're gonna go guys all right
we added I started wrapping this up at
the hour mark and we've dragged another
11 minutes out of it Greg we did we we
and then we just kept going watch
time brilliant well thanks a lot guys
and uh yeah we'll try work something out
much love peace